[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
cell-based spr microscopy applications
and drug discovery with pfizer
i am michelle ashton of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by biosensing instruments to learn
more visit biosensingusa.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
shiji wu application scientist
biosensing instrument
and jonathan brooks principal scientist
pfizer pharmaceuticals
chichi and jonathan you may now begin
your presentations
thanks for the introduction my name is
shidawu
from biosensing instrument
today i'm going to talk about the basic
principles and applications of surface
plasma resonance microscopy
before we start talking about
sprm please allow me to say a couple of
words about biosensing instrument
boxing's instrument is located in
arizona usa and we started in 2005.
so since
2005 we have developed a series of
platforms for specialty spr environment
particularly
in 2017
we developed this new tech
platform called sprm
which is very well recognized by the
industry and received quite a few awards
from different institutions and it's
also very well recognized to receive a
lot of interest from researchers all
over the world
sprm is the label-free technique that
allows you to
directly counter a cell onto the spr
chip surface therefore you can study the
binding kinetic with memory proteins
directly on the cell surface close to
their physiology conditions
it can provide a real-time analysis
and give you the binding
parameters including the association and
the dissociation rate constant and the
binding affinity
it can also be used to study some
nanostructures and nanoparticles
including species like virus bacterias
and so on
sprm has three key components the first
component is the spr unit it includes
the license the detector and the sensor
chip
on top of this spr unit it is a
bradfield optical microscope which
essentially illuminates the same area or
looking at the same area this optical
microscope allows you to precisely
position and locate the sample to where
you want to do the experiment they also
allow you to monitor the status of the
sample during the experiment
the last component is a uniquely
designed
flow system and this uniquely designed
the flow system provides the uh
optimized flow conditions to ensure
accurate spr environment and also allow
you to directly culture the cells onto
the chip surface and maintain the
measurement conditions during the
experiment
by combining all three of the components
and the system allow us to measure the
parameters of the binary kinetics
including kylo and k off and the binding
affinity
this is how
optical system and the
chip
well
looks like in a real system the
optical
microscope looks from the top of the
chip
the polymer well
sits on top of the gold chip
and the gold tip can be functionalized
chemically for culturing of different
cell lines
most commonly they will be used
like collagen
pll and pdl
etc
after the experiment done the data will
be saved in a series of
images including the upright field and
the sprs
and then we'll divide the whole area
into a
number of small regions we call the
region of interest
so usually it will be around like 600 up
to 7000 depending on the time you want
to spend for the calculation or the
compute computation
uh
and then for each of the roi will
generate a sensor graph so most of the
time the experiment is done in a
kinetic titration kind of fashion
so which means it will go from low
concentration to high concentration just
continuously injecting one after another
and once we have all the sensor graphs
generated and then we'll feed those data
to the one-to-one binding model
and then we'll apply the binding filter
and to remove all those non-specific
bindings and leave only the good
specific bindings corresponding to the
molecule and the
receptors on the cell
and from those we can get a histogram a
distribution and which will give us the
average uh kl and okay off and also the
affinity
now i will show you a number of examples
for the binding measurement using uh
sprm so this is one of the nice
experiments we done with uh astrazeneca
and the system we are looking at is a
small molecule az1395
targeting the dvr39 receptor on lg ksl
the results is shown here on the left
this is a
spi image and on the right is a
corresponding optical image
and the optical image you can see more
clearly where all the ftk cells are
located on the ship's surface
and each of the color square on the
surface reflects one of the good areas
giving you a good binding data
and you can see immediately the good
binding data comes overlaps with the
position of the cell very well so this
tells us we are looking at
the bindings happening on the cell not
on some equity areas
and with all the data
we
analyze we can obtain the isotherm from
which
we can
obtain the binding affinity
based on the thermodynamic analysis we
also have all the sensograms for each of
the units area and we can feed the
kinetic model the one-to-one binding
kinetic model by each of the sensor gram
and from the fitting we can obtain the
uh
the value
the average value of the kl and the k
off and also the binding affinity and
also we see the because we are looking
at many different
areas and we get a distribution
histogram which shows the uh
variation
of the heterogeneity between the
different cells or the different parts
of the surface
so the results we obtained for the
binding affinity is about 400
nanomolar and the corresponding kn and
ko
reported also here and this molecule is
actually very well studied by
astrazeneca and other researchers
so
one of the results reported
in the literature using a technique
called the bsi which is the back
scattering interferometer
and it gives the value about 233
nanomolar which upgrades very well with
our measurement down
here this is another small molecule
example
binding to the membrane transporter and
it's the data from casey
and in this experiment we have
positive mining and also negative
control samples and you can see for the
positive experiment
there's a nice
binding
data and for the negative essentially no
binding is observed
in the
on the cell
now this is actually a very interesting
example
in this case we have a bivalent
antibody and binds to the
vr's results
and this is uh data is from genetech and
we actually have a very
good
webinar with ilimai
and
she gave a very good presentation if you
are interested you can
go to the my webinar
and what is interesting here is with the
bivalent antibody and we do see two
binding peaks
well most of the
examples
we've been working with are like the
hearing cells they are very easier to
culture
on the chip surface
and
some of the researchers they are
interested in looking at live
suspension
cells
and the question is can we really do
suspension cells
and this example shows
the possibility that we
do
testing with visa
and it is uh
done in collaboration with uh zhang from
pfizer usa john is the expert on this
and he's going to give a very nice
present presentation later on about his
results
and what is nice here is we have the
lifestyle and we grab it onto the cheap
surface and then we run the usual
experiment
and what we obtains is the ka kd and
also the affinity and here is the
sensorgrams for
those
regions of interest that shows on the
optical and the sapr image
this is another interesting experiment
and down by a signature the system will
be looking at is just small molecule
targeting the nts1 receptor which is
indirectly expressed on the breast
cancer cell
again the results is shown on the
top images the middle image which is the
optical image and you can see where all
the cells is located and the
corresponding spr image is shown on the
right
the left side is the fluorescence image
and
used to
validate or to prove the expression
level of the nts1 receptor on the cell
the analyzed data is reflected by those
colored squares on the image and again a
actually overlaps with the position of
the cells very well
and the results will be obtained from
the measurement and gives the
affinity the big kid value about two
nanomolars
this particular
receptor the nts1 receptor this protein
actually has been purified
and studied by
dr huber from rush in britain uk
and she actually used conventional spr
and purifies this
receptor and lead the conventional
measurement for the same molecule
and the results she reported
is about
400 picomolars for the binding affinity
in the literature there's also some in
vitro uh
studies
for different type of ats-1 receptors
and for the wild type and human type
it
gives different values about like uh
500 pico motors and to eight uh nano
motors
and our sprm gives the data about two
nanomolar so which actually fairly
agrees very well with those natural
studies
sprm can be combined with
other techniques like electrochemistry
so we can actually add a potential stat
to the system
and then we can supply uh
electric modulation
and to the system and then using the
spr imaging capability to monitor the
local responses of the
chip surface the materials on the chip
surface to the
electric modulation
here are two examples for the
electrochemical applications with sprm
the first one
is the spr based impedance
experiment
so what we're looking at is the
responses of
seahawk cell to the
populaces treatment
and you have the optical image the spr
image and the spr based
uh
impedance image so the spr
based impedance image shows the
localized responses
of those cells to the trimet and
the second example it shows the cv using
the cv to study the
individual gold nanowires on the chip
surface so each of the gold nanowire and
we're showing up with the interference
pattern on the image and they can be
labeled
from here so for each of the good
nanowires
and you can have a cv
based on the
[Music]
the spr signal so you can see the
depending on the size and the
the the conductivities and those
different properties of the individual
gold wires and they actually see
differences in the cv
so which just proves those nano wires
are not uniform they have different
physical shapes and
skills and the properties
thanks for listening to this
presentation
and in summary sprm is a very unique and
label-free technique that allow you to
directly do measurements on the
cells and to work with membrane proteins
directly
without
extracting them from the system
uh
with this and i will pass the time to
job for his interesting research
thank you
thank you gigi my name is jonathan
brooks and i work for pfizer in
cambridge massachusetts i work in
individual pharmacology group which is
embedded within the inflammation and
immunology research unit
today i'd like to talk about the kinetic
characterization of ligand and antibody
binding to cell surface expressed ccrl2
using surface plasmon resonance
microscopy
so this is the outline from my talk
today
just briefly i'd like to go over our
group here at pfizer and then move into
the ccrl2 that we're going to be talking
about
the biology and the ligands
and then the initial data that was
performed to look at the binding of
ligands to ccrl2 using flow cytometry
and then i'll get into the binding
kinetics that i performed using first
the ligand tracer and then of course the
bulk of the work using sprm microscopy
the in vitro pharmacology group within
the ini unit here in cambridge uh is
responsible for supporting programs from
discovery all the way through first in
human
within my small group we use a suite of
biophysical platforms to
help in this effort
we look at both small and large molecule
targets here in the group
so that keeps things interesting
you can see some of the technologies
below that i use starting with protein
characterization
and then moving on to performing binding
assays using
traditional biosensors
on the bottom of the slide you can see
some of the technologies that we use for
looking at
cell binding
we can do
steady state cell affinities using the
kinexa and we can perform binding
kinetics using a ligand tracer and now
most recently we can perform binding
kinetics using the sprm200 from
sensing
we do have a corning epic that we
have used on occasion as well to look at
interactions of small molecules to
cells
within
pfizer here in cambridge we do have
access to
many technology core centers throughout
the site and these are invaluable in
helping us in our discovery efforts
you can see them listed here flow
cytometry high content imaging
microscopy mass spectrometry and
next-gen sequencing and we can't do
things on our own we certainly go to
them their expertise to help us move
programs along
so ccrl 2
the
cell surface target that we're going to
be talking about today is a
non-signaling gpcr
it's upregulated during inflammation
uh shown here
and it what
establishes itself as a chemokine
gradient and as
ccrl2
is expressed on these endothelial cells
chemokines will come and bind them
and we thought that these chemokines
will then act as a target of interest
for other inflammatory cells to then
bind and then potentially hopefully lead
to some
type of a response
again because
ccrl2 is non-signaling there's no
downstream
event that we can measure when looking
at this target
such as a phosphorylation event
there are many reported ligands in
literature for
ccrl2
chemeran and ccl2 are two that i'll talk
about today but you can see the others
listed here
chemeran and ccl2 are quite small
compared to
any body binding
i just wanted to
make a note of their molecular weights
here so my goal with this was to use
sprm to help better understand the
biology around ccrl2
and look at the binding of this ligands
to to this
cell surface express target
the initial work looking at ligand's
binding to ccrl2 was performed using a
high throughput flow cytometry assay
shown here
as you can see the cells were
plated into the 384 well plate and then
biotinylated ligands were added followed
by secondary agents
what you can see here in this diagram is
a binding of chemeran to ccrl2 expressed
on the over expressing cells with a
really nice
binding curve cc50
and what you're not seeing is binding by
ccl2
in this particular assay
also at the same time
antibodies will evaluate binding you can
see the
commercial reagent here from r d systems
and the bio legend antibody
both binding
ccrl2 on these cells with very nice
ec50s
and no binding by the isotype
controlling body
one of the first things i did when i
started my work on this effort was to do
a ligand tracer binding experiment
ligand tracer uses fluorescently labeled
analytes to measure on rates and off
rates to cell surface target receptors
shown here in the schematic cells are
plated onto a dish in spots
you can have your current you can have
your over expressing cells or your
parental cells in two separate spots
then you rotate the spots through your
media containing your fluorescently
labeled analyte of interest
as it analyte binds you see an increase
in fluorescence response
when you're
done collecting your on rate data you
can then remove the media containing
analyte replace it with media alone and
monitor the dissociation of the bound
complex
so for my effort with ligand tracer
i spotted two spots with
two over expressing cells and then two
spots of parental cells
these were attached on uh collagen
coated uh areas of the dish
then i tested kemeron that i labeled
with alexa 48 and 100 animal one
you can see the binding
shown here by the thick lines the red
and the blue to the over expressing
cells and then the
thinner lines of the parentals
so we subtract that the parental from
the overexpressing and you get the
subtracted data shown here by the black
sensograms
and then the red fit lines so we fit
this now to a one-to-one binding you can
see
in the table below the binding affinity
the on rate the off rate and the binding
affinity which is very similar to that
that was shown by the ec 50 on the
flow cytometry assay
so
to investigate this further i wanted to
use sprm
to perform binding of a panel of
analytes to
cells expressing ccrl2
and then also the appropriate control
assays
using the parental non-expressing cells
so we coded cells onto the chambers the
cell chambers using either collagen or
poly
we coded the cells around 50 to 100 000
and incubated them in the incubator
until they were confluent
and ready for testing
on the day of the test we would
fix the cells with pfa
or we would just test them live and the
running buffer was pbs with 0.1 bsa
over here you can see the samples that i
tested chemoran in-house and then the
rnd systems ccl2 and then the three
anti-ccrl2 antibodies shown here
along with isotope control anybody
and from an operational standpoint we
ran a three minute on rate
uh
10 minute off rate and then the flow was
150 micrometers per minute there was no
regeneration between the samples but we
did have a 10 minute wait between each
of the samples tested
and we tested three to four samples per
day
on multiple days
so when you perform an sprm experiment
the data analysis is pretty streamlined
and i just thought i'd
show what i did
to analyze the data for this particular
batch of samples
in the top panel here you can see the
bright field image with the green spr
overlay that's everywhere where there's
an spr effect occurring
the area where there's no cells the gray
area
there's no spr occurring
we overlay the
area with what we call regions of
interest and so each one of these
squares is a region of interest and each
one of these squares is going to
generate a binding response
that will be measured
and that's shown here in the raw
response you can see this stacked
overlay of sensograms in the
concentration dependent manner from low
concentration to high
similar to what you'd see in a single
cycle kinetics binding experiment
the cell free area
where there's no cells generates a
minimal response which is subtracted
from the raw response and then we do a
buffer injection
uh which again is
referenced from the var response so
double referencing the data
the data is then
cut and stacked
shown here and then it's fit to the
binding wall you can see the red fit
lines over the
binding data
because there's so much data it's uh
nice to
well it's easier to
view as a distribution plot because
there's many
on rates and off rates that make up
these binding affinities that are
calculated into a mean value shown here
in the end the data that was used
for the final analysis is shown you can
see the regions of interest that were
used for the accepted data fit
so
this is the
data for the binding to the fixed cells
here we
have taken the cells and fixed them and
tested the ligands for binding starting
with kemarin
in the top you can see the ribbon
diagram just to remind us all that
chemin's not an antibody it's a lot
smaller
and you can see the regions of interest
in the accepted fit here
and then the stacked
plots here
then the distributions the on rate the
off rate the binding infinity very
similar to what was observed uh both by
ligand tracer and
postside geometry
next up is the antibodies the r d
systems two three five zero
two three five zero one and then the
five legend
and what you can see is a nice um
stacked overlay plot it's binding
sensograms um one thing you'll see uh in
this data it's negative curves and
that's not indicative of non-specific
binding like you
traditionally would think using a
traditional biosensor it's more
response of the spr
on the cell and thereby generating a
negative finding a negative response but
it's actually some really nice binding
data there
so it's something to
get used to when working with the sprm
system
again the on rate distribution the off
rate distribution and the binding
infinity for the two three five zero
and then the two three five zero one the
biology body
one thing we did
observe when testing against fixed cells
was no binding by ccl2 or the isotype
controlling the body
now i'll show you that against the live
cell data
and now we're binding to live cells and
in this plot you can see kemeron binding
the ccrl2 on live cells
you can see the regions of interest that
were used for the accepted fit in the
bright field image here and there's many
of them and then you can see these
stacked
fit plot here
good distribution of the affinity shown
here and then the odd rate in the
off-road distribution shown on the
bottom
you can see in the spr image some
brighter areas
in the
window and these are indicative of very
high spr responses that are
in the plot
up here
now here you i'm showing the ccl2 and
the isotope control which did not bind
to the
ccrl2 on live cells and what you see
this is what we see what
we don't get any binding it's just very
few
rois that end up in the image
there's really no binding going on at
all here both for the ccl2 or the
isotype control
and we get very little data they can't
be
really anything done with it in terms of
getting uh on rates or off rates or or
an affinity for that matter
i will say we didn't see any binding to
the parental cells with any of the
samples that we
tested
this is the binding to the parental
cells i
instead of showing the bright field
images with the very few rois i'm just
showing the binding incidents here that
would be on
binding histograms
if you look closely you can see on the
y-axis there's very few binding that's
occurring here for chemoran
bio-legend
the rnd systems antibodies
and also the exotic control so
this is what we typically see
when we have no non-binding events
occurring on the
cells of interest
now we're back to binder antibody two
three five zero from rng systems
binding to ccrl2 expressed on the live
cells you can see some really nice roi
pattern here and some um the fit
data here and a good infinity
distribution of the data as well as the
on the off rate
data as well
and anybody two three five zero one
not as good as two three five zero in
this instance but still
measurable binding and decent binding
kinetics and affinity
and then the bio legend antibody shown
here
generated quite large response units
which has made it really hard to see the
actual
fit lines within the data but still
excellent binding infinity by this
antibody and good rate kinetics
so
i just thought at this point before i
summarize i'd like to show some data of
camera and binding to live cells on
separate days
because of the nature of the system of
having to grow the cells on the chips
and prepare them for each run you do get
different cell states and different cell
densities when you perform the
assay
and that's just shown here day one day
two day three each day is a different
chip and each one contains a different
you know
area of
cells that were used for the binding you
can see
different areas within those days where
the cells bound
to generate spi response with cameron
but
if you do look at the data and you look
at the curves
and more importantly if you look at the
binding distributions what you can see
is pretty good consistency and on-rate
off-rate and binding affinity
from the three separate days of chemo
analysis
much
maybe not as tight as you'd see with a
common protein on a traditional
biosensor but certainly very
very tight for a live cell system
looking at binding kinetics
so summarizing the data here
you can see chemo and binding to fixed
and live cells on three separate days
very similar bond rates off rates and
binding affinity
and again that holds true with the r d
systems
uh two three five zero map the two three
five zero one and then the violet legend
antibody h302
and
again we saw no binding by ccl2
to either fixed or alive cells and also
we saw no binding by isotope control
and again
as i mentioned previously we didn't see
any binding of any of these analytes to
the parental non-expressing cells
so in summary
we used the sprm to look at various
ligands binding to both fixed and live
cells expressing ccrl2
and we were able to generate pretty
robust rate kinetic values
for both cell states
no binding was observed by ccl2 or the
ice type controlling anybody
and no binding was observed to parental
cells not expressing ccrl2
the binding that we did generate
did
uh agree well with the other labeled i
underline that techniques the flow
cytometry and the ligand tracer
and just
to summarize it shows that sprm is a
powerful tool
for label-free analysis of ligands
binding in the cell surface targets
and has allowed us to generate these
rate constants and infinity values and
help us better understand
the biology surrounding these cell
service targets
and with that i'd just like to thank you
for your attention
and acknowledge a few folks before i uh
take some questions
in particular genre sue who
performed all the flow cytometry data
and if it wasn't with for his effort i
wouldn't have been able to um work on my
hands using the sprm
i'd like to thank joe
brennan and paul morgan joe was
instrumental in getting this project
going and uh reached out to me to
perform the sprm
and lastly i'd like to thank the folks
from biosensing
nguyen gigi and akimi for their help and
support
troubleshooting and
and allowing me to speak with you today
and with that i'll take any questions
thank you
thank you shiji and jonathan for your
informative presentations we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
our first question is surface of the
cell has many receptors
how does sprm detect the binding of my
specific target receptor
okay
this is actually i will take this
question
so actually in the presentation as there
is you know many
examples
show
how we deal with this so essentially you
know you need to
overexpress
the receptors you are interested
and also a good way of um you know
confirm the experiment is to writing
negative experiments
and i use negative controls so by
combining all those you know different
experimental designs so you will be sure
you are actually
looking at the
receptors you are interested
okay
yeah
john's here to dump me want to add
something
i believe he's reconnecting his audio so
he should be joining us back in just a
moment um in the meantime um i do have
another question here for you okay
and the question is what is the range of
affinities that can be measured by sprm
uh
okay that's the interesting question the
uh
exactly the sprm so
even though it's uh it's a different
detection mechanism but the uh
measurement range is
usually in the
times of pico motors to micromotors
fantastic thank you
okay our next question how did you
capture the suspension cells on the chip
um
yeah the the chip is that's actually one
of the advantages of sprm so we don't
have to extract the uh
the memory proteins from the cell so we
for the sus i mean for the suspension
cells
we can actually culture i mean
capture it with certain
functionalized coatings
on the gold surface so including like a
pll
and pdl and
cell cell attack and
exactly uh john is actually the first
say on
pioneers you know onto
working with the sprm
with suspension cells and john you may
want to add something more of this
but just you having trouble with the
audios
can you hear me okay
yeah i can't hear you now yeah so we are
yeah
yeah so um
with suspension cells it's
you have to
you have to test them um with various um
attachments um to see which ones work
best
i found uh through trial and error for
particular um suspension cells
that um
you know collagen might work better for
others for for a particular set of cells
than say fibrinectin or polyd lysine
you just have to
see how the cells look and then
sometimes you can um
you know it's also how well they'll um
adhere because under flow
uh cells
have you know washed away on me before
so you have to find something that's
going to adhere the cells but also keep
them you know relatively happy
okay great thank you both
okay our next question um how can you
minimize the interference of optical
pathway
each other which is spr light and
optical microscope light
okay
that's a very interesting question i
think whoever asking this question is
the expert
um yeah we do uh actually uh use a
custom design optical path
exactly to isolate the light path from
the optical illumination
from the spr
and to avoid the interference between
the bright field light and the
laser or the spr
great thank you
now does the cell do the cells um let's
see
does the cells be suspension cells or
can we use um adherent cells too
oh you can use
oh
you can use both adherent cells or
suspension cells but
they need to be
still attached to some type of a medium
because the slides used in the
instrument are glass
so
you know you still have to stick them on
there using some type of an attachment
medium yeah education is also theory
actually a little bit easier like you
know again
in general term
i mean yeah
[Music]
great thank you both your next question
are cells fixed or treated in any way to
immobilize them on the chips or to keep
them stationary during analysis
um
oh sorry fiji no go ahead go ahead
i've i've always
attached the cells
live
because i've grown them in the incubator
um on the attachment medium and then
when they reach a certain level of
confluency
i will remove them and then i'm going to
test live i'll test live but if i'm
going to fix them that's when i'll fix
them i'll fix them
right before i perform the run so i
wouldn't attached um
you know cells that were
i guess modified or fixed onto a cell
surface if that's what the question is
i i would fix them after they've grown
and then perform the run
okay great now john this next question
is for you
did you examine or are you aware of any
small molecule molecule binding studies
via sprm with this or other receptors
um
i've
i've looked at small molecules binding
to other cell surface targets
using spray microscopy uh here at pfizer
i have not looked at any small molecules
to ccrl to just the the goal for this
was to look at the antibodies and
cameron
okay thank you
now this next question is a three-part
question
what mode of spr detection is used
is it more similar to spr imagery
imaging and is
is reflectivity being measured angle of
reflection
uh well in the scrm exactly yeah we do
actually marry the reflectivity
and i use that to
calculate the shape in the response
angle
thank you gg
does the gold surface work as an
electrode in cb combination
oh yeah that's true yeah i mean so if
you try to combine the scrm with
so the
the gold chip
will work as the working electrode
and uh is the electrochemical setup is
actually very similar to the
conventional three electrodes uh
setup so you have the reference and the
counter electrode and
of course there are many electrodes
[Music]
working the
cell culture
well
okay our next question how were you able
to determine if there's a one-to-one
interaction
um well the thing is we when we look at
those findings is you know we assume the
uh
it's a simple one-to-one binding and
they use that model to use
to feed the data
and then based on that fittings and we
eliminated those uh
uh
those uh sensograms which doesn't fit
very well or gave a large dvds a lot
from the one to one binding
and
you know there's always uh some some
people asking like a complicated meeting
and uh you can accommodate like a
complicated
mathematical models
uh of you know kinetic models but then
the remorse the heating will increase as
well
so for the um
for the for the experiment we are doing
for the analysis we are doing so we
essentially feed the data to the one to
one
binding mode
great thank you
what is the difficulty of implementing
and method development for sbrm when
compared to sativa t200 system
uh i can say a couple words and i think
john may
has lots of experience on it too and uh
i mean basically this is two different
uh we are looking at two different
systems i mean they are all str of
course um but uh the major difference is
you know the uh the t200 is the
conventional str so you need to extract
the uh
the
samples the proteins or the receptor
proteins
from the cell and they uniformly you
know prepare the chip surface
and i think the major difficulty for
that is extracting how do you purify the
proteins from the cell
and in the scrm so we basically overcome
that just step
and we directly culture the cell onto
the chip surface and work with the
receptors
in the native
cell surface
so now you want to elaborate reason
yeah it's um
it's it's much different than that um
you know an uh an spr a traditional spr
system because you're dealing with live
cells and you have to culture the cells
on the chip
and then set up the
binding
like a
traditional biosensor you have to be
aware of your buffers
that in this case might impact the cells
um so you you have to be careful with
what buffer system you use you don't
want to damage the cell because in in
this instance you know my cells were
live
so you don't want to um
you know use something very harsh like a
very high percentage of dmso or
something like that
also
this also comes in the throughput you
you can't like a traditional biosensor
run hundreds of samples at a time
because of
the live nature of the cells
you can operate within a window of you
know so many hours
where you think your cells will be most
viable before they might start to you
know go off
and that's something to be aware of also
when when
performing assay development using the
system
okay great thank you jonathan this one's
for you how did the small
molecules evaluated against other cell
surface receptors performed
via sprm in terms of
data robustness consistency with
expected kinetics affinities etc
with
some of the experience i've had using
small molecules performing small
molecule binding using sprm i've
actually had some very nice data
with a panel a small panel of small
molecules that i looked at with a range
of
binding affinities
that were
generated first using a biochemical
assay and my data from the sprm tracked
quite nicely with the
with that data
so that that was very
very very nice but also i would say
um
[Music]
you have to be careful with small
molecules they can if they're if they're
um if they're
you know promiscuous i would say and and
could bind to other things
you have to have a control cell
available to make sure you're not just
looking at something that's non-specific
so ideally for every small molecule or
any protein protein experiment i do i'd
like to have a negative control
cell something that's a non-expressor
and also have a negative control
compound or a protein
as well
okay great
can you go into the details of how we
can interpret the negative curves
well
the negative curves that you see on the
um on the sprm
are
you know they're if
if you've ever run a
biosensor experiment using a um an octet
octet cat
generates negative curves as well and um
you know
their software you can flip the curves
so they become positive and then you fit
the data as you would
in this instance you just have to get
used to looking at curves that are
negative that the negative curve is
really an spr phenomenon it's not
necessarily a binding phenomenon i've
had curves that look almost
identical
that are negative and positive and and
it's just it's the same data but it's
just um it's just expressed on the
you know from the software and from the
spr negatively so
you just get used to it in this instance
okay uh well actually um yeah i think
that's just uh
there's uh there's some you know uh
fundamental differences i mean kind of
uh how we actually do the measurement
with the sprm
with the lifestyle
so
you know in here you know there's
research papers you know published so in
here we are looking at you know the when
you have the binding of the cell surface
and the binary cause some like
physical properties changes to the cell
including like a stiffness and
morphology changes and all those
parameters kind of transfer to the scr
signal
responses we are looking at so that
depends on the how the cells responses
to the binding sometimes you know we do
can see an
active curve instead of
a positive increase in the signal like
most of the people see
in a conventional spr but those
those curve the sensorogram even though
it's a negative response it still
perfectly reflects the
kinetic process the binding process
that's what i want to add thank you gigi
we have time for a few more questions
here
can we optimize the surface area
according to our cell number
um i i could take that a little um
you have to have a minimum number of
cells to be able to generate a robust
spr response you don't want to have too
few cells and that's again that comes
with assay development when you're
growing the cells on the surface you
want to have
enough cells
that that you'll be able to get a good
enough response um
binding to your target and um
and um
you don't want to have um you know too
too many and then you don't have any
referencing you don't want to have too
many cells so
it's uh
it's something that needs to be
optimized and it's of course receptor
dependent if you have an over expressing
cell line you might be able to get away
with fewer cells than you would with say
a
native cell that has a fewer
level of receptors on the surface of the
cells
okay great thank you
your next question sbr instruments offer
a tremendous throughput
often testing hundreds of recombinant
purified proteins in less than 24 hours
what is the s prm throughput
oh johnny would a comment on that
um
yeah it it
you have to um take into account what
type of target you're looking at and
again the expression level of the target
for for the work i did with these tcrl2
antibodies i was using an over express
cell line and i felt comfortable
you know testing three to four
antibodies uh per run
knowing that um these were fairly high
affinity and that there was probably
going to be some antibodies still
bound
when i came through for the next
antibody binding but i knew there would
be excess
receptors available
for binding and that and that played out
when i did the uh analysis so
it's it's that's certainly not as high
as you would get with a traditional
biosensor
the system is automated it has a uh you
know a great uh user interface it's it's
it is just
set up your plate
load everything start the run and walk
away so you could conceivably do
i would think depending on you know if
it was a small molecule if you were just
screening a single concentration or or
maybe you know a high and a low
concentration you could probably do
tens of twenties of samples
if if things were really well optimized
um i've probably run at any one given
time the load the highest number of
samples i've run is maybe five
um
and again that it it takes a while
because there are you know many washes
and things like that just like a
traditional biosensor but you're
certainly not going to get the
throughput you would with
compared to a traditional biosensor
that being said i would say it's much
faster than other cell-based systems
such as ligand tracer
which you know you need to label each of
your analytes for that this is label
free there's no labeling required
yeah i mean bottom line i mean sprm is
not designed for like a fast screening
technique
okay great thank you both we've got time
for one last question here
what is the running buffer used in sprm
are analytes diluted in this buffer is
it a growth media
well i guess that depends on the
experiment the cell line you are using
so in general
and i mean the system itself doesn't
really have you know a limitation
and
on it and you can use pretty much every
kind of general
buffer system
and it depends on the cell line
depending on the experiment and for life
cells and you may want to use
some buffers to keep the cell you know
happy or as long as possible
yeah yeah
yeah i agree it depends on the system um
if they're fixed cells you can just use
a standard pbs buffer with
bsa
for the binding
that's what i used with fixed but for
live cells you might want to switch it
up and
try to do something that's going to keep
some the cells happier
comes down to method development at that
point
all right well thank you both gigi and
jonathan for your time today do either
of you have any final comments for our
audience before we close
uh well go ahead
a lot of questions on here i'm sorry we
couldn't answer them all i could try
offline i guess
yeah i think happy to you know have
everyone here and i will definitely try
to get all the answers back to everyone
and if you have any questions uh you
know after the
uh the presentation i mean
the webinar and you can
always contact us
yes and as a reminder any questions that
we didn't have time for today and
questions that are submitted during the
on-demand period
they will be addressed by our speakers
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration so
again we'd like to thank our speakers
we'd also like to thank biosensing
instrument for underwriting today's
educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event thank you everyone until next
time
you